one of them is you have to have a  willingness to fail  you have to have a willingness to be  misunderstood for long periods of time  if you do something in a new way  i don't care  what it is  people are initially  going to misunderstand it relative to  the traditional way and they will  they'll be well-meaning critics  who  you know genuinely  want the best outcome but they're  worried about this new way  and they'll also be of course  self-interested critics  who have a vested interest  in the  traditional they have some profit stream  tied to the traditional way  but  but doing things and if you want to if  you never want to be criticized for  goodness sake don't do anything new